hey everyone so you're all still
filtering in there's a lot of you and
you're from where I stand quite up scary
hi some of you I can't really see
because of the lights that I do this it
just means that I'm being blinded hello
at the back hello well I don't know if
you guys might not know you might never
been up here but this thing is kind of
suspended over the actual stadium down
below and when you walk upon it it kind
of bounces under your feet in a way that
it says to you do you trust the
engineering skills of the guys that put
this up
look at those cables that's all that's
between me and certain death
yeah hence the the kind of blue M&Ms
story from Van Halen okay I will just
while you're finding your seats I will
do kind of the boring bit where I talk
about me so don't panic if you're
towards to the end there people on the
sides if you could all shuffle in
towards the middle a little bit that
would probably really help because
otherwise the folks on the side are
having to climb all the way up to the
back some of them may be suffering
altitude sickness at this point already
okay for those of you don't know while
sitting down my name is Ian Cooper
hopefully especially those of you packed
in the middle you've come to hear me
talk about clean architecture and dotnet
if you're in the middle and you're
expecting to talk about Ruby or
something I'm sorry but you may be in
trouble now okay this is kind of my bio
and it's really fairly dull it just says
I'm old but the key point as to what I
always try and mention is the one in the
bottom right which is I would really
encourage you not to believe there's any
difference between you and me I am NOT
special I'm not better than anybody here
I'm just other dev I just happened to
get into standing on this side of the
stage because frankly when I started
doing net no one was talking and I was
running a user group so we had to I had
to get out myself it is really good for
you to do it it helps you organize your
thoughts it helps you think about
material how you present it to others it
makes you think about how you how
articulate your opinions and I would
encourage all of you to have a go find a
local user group there'll be people that
want to help you and try and get in
despairing your thoughts of people okay
please do try and stand up you are just
as good as me and that's why I work for
you're probably uninterested in who I
work for the only thing to say about it
is I work for a software company not a
consultancy I'm trying to sell you
anything
I have no books this is an open source
project called bright so that I work on
you'll see some code examples towards
the end that use brighter it is a CQRS
library it is a task you library and
there's a messaging library it's similar
to say mediator and mass transit and
we're lucky enough to have 20% time at
Huddle's so we can spend quite a bit of
time supporting and working on this
particular platform please do check it
out I do have some stickers in my bag
down here I can put them on the table
anyone fancy is a brighter sticker for
their laptop they're kind of cool we
couldn't get Scott Hanson to pay any
attention as a project and
so we had stickers once we had stickers
Scot cared about us so he wants a
sticker come and grab one off me at the
end okay we can talk about so I'll talk
start off by having I sought a bit of a
tiny chat about loose coupling and high
cohesion because they're kind of
relevant to what we're doing today then
we'll go back and talk about layers
right because layers are really the key
to understanding what clean architecture
is we'll talk about domain models
because some of the interesting bits
about cleaning architectures are how you
deal with a domain model and what is
what is in lives in entities what lives
in interactors or ports whatever you're
going to call the depending on your
preference and then we'll talk a little
bit about this idea from Bob Martin
called the clean architecture explicitly
and then I will probably deal a little
bit with this issue of how you implement
ports interactors we're going to call
them because that seems to be the bit
that most people struggle with when
they're trying to work on this kind of
project and I've got a little example
piece of code will take through it goes
from sort of just a MVC app that's
essentially got over all the coding
aligned and the controller and we'll
show you basically putting that in
different places to try and improve the
design of that application so the term
clean architecture just to really cool
it out was one that came from Bob Martin
and he's got a book called clean
architecture the book tends to have a
lot of his material about being clean so
bob has this whole series of books which
used to work clean to effectively mean
well engineered very modifiable code and
the clean architecture book takes some
of his existing ideas that you all know
and loud solid principles etc and talks
about them in an architectural context
but the core idea of the book
he's also mentioned a virus blogposts is
this idea that there is a architectural
style which he calls the cleaner
architecture which is a very useful
approach to a large number of systems
particularly most line of business
systems
now Bob's pretty clear that that's not
his idea what he's doing when he calls
it cleaner architecture is actually
collating a number of ideas that have
actually occurred to various people over
the history of computing and some
particular call-outs we might want to
make at this point who inspired this
idea of clean architecture one of the
key ones is Alastair Coburn with the
ports and adapters or hexagonal
architecture for steps is the technical
name it's often referred to as hexagonal
because the diagram was essentially have
hexagonal shapes in them the Jeffrey
Palermo Craig in in the.net space come
up with this idea called the onion
architecture and a long time ago back in
the 90s I become some came up with this
idea called boundaries controllers and
entities or BCE they are all essentially
variations of the same thing they are
all rediscoveries of this same ideal
architecture you know we get this kind
of thing that happens in computing is
that we continually reinvent everything
you know everything was actually
invented in small talk back and lean in
1980 or whatever cetera but the reality
is we just keep reinventing the same
kind of ideas and what bob was calling
out is there's this common theme to the
set of ideas as to how we would organize
our architecture that seems to have
evolved quite independently amongst
these individual practitioners but if
you look at it are essentially saying
the same thing and what we'll do in this
presentation is we'll wander through a
few those different kind of reach to get
there because actually having a range of
them helps us to really understand each
one because so for example cut ports and
adapters one of the questions people
often have is or what is a port I get
what the adaptor is what the domain is
what is the port and if we look at other
ideas like BCE or just simple service
facades or the onion architecture
actually we can get a clearer idea of
some of those more confusing pieces all
right
let me show you first of all some code
yeah where am i okay you just switched
the rapper okay so this is a pretty
standard don't know cool you know one
seed at the back going to make a bit
bigger can make it bigger bigger bigger
right because you're all the way at the
back that's one bigger that's good
excellent this is a really standard
dotnet core Web API app the kind of
thing that I'm sure you build or you've
built a version in you know MVC web web
api for Precor or you've used I'd know
Nancy or open raster but it's a fairly
standard lighter thing right and all we
have here is essentially a control room
we have advert various methods that
receive HTTP requests on here so we can
say I want to basically get I can see we
can say get by ID
I've got post and I've essentially got
to delete now what this application is
actually doing I will show you by
looking some tests
so this application every every you know
every speaker needs to have their demo
application I decided to create the
world's most over engineered hello world
application because you have to have a
domain simple enough to explain in about
two minutes and then we ready cope late
with the fact that simple simple domains
don't help you so essentially what we
can do is we can get a whole list of
greetings we can post a new greeting
hello world or you can see hello Mary or
hello Alice right and we can delete
greetings now somewhere over here I can
probably spin this off and show you that
actually works that's a quick look if
you just don't want this one
this bit is I mean if you can't read it
is unexcited I just need to build this
piece of software and then run docker to
run it so if you can't read it don't
panic there's nothing here that you
really want to care about but when we
flip back over here what you'll see is
that all of the code is essentially
inlined into the controller so when I do
a get I'm simply going to get a greeting
context that's basically an entity
framework context just standard ng
framework boilerplate code with a set of
basically my greeting objects and then I
can turn them into an array and then I
turn those arrays into some kind of view
model object my greeting ID result and
then I put out my greetings all result
essentially as a return and good old
asp.net is going to return that into
some nice piece of Jason for me that
represents essentially my actual objects
and when I what's post yeah
ignore this these few lines we'll come
back to it later I'm grabbing a context
I'm creating a new item I'm saving the
item essentially and then I go and
retrieve the item just put in the
database and I then return okay and give
his representation I'd like to search it
from the database and let the asp.net
runtime take care for me of basically
turning that object into some lovely
jason that goes on the back end and
we're running through that reasonably
fast because i'm sure that you've all
built apps like this many times okay
and just so you can see it working
we can run some tests against this file
so I can send a request and you see back
it's saying to me right well you've got
an empty database is 200 okay and I can
stick a request in so basically goes
away and it says okay I'll put on that
date entry into the database and then
you can and then I'll quarry the
database with the ideas got inserted
I'll get the item out and I'll basically
put the JSON back out onto basically the
wall I for you and you can see basically
I've now got the idea that item added so
now if I get all the items you can see
that I've got that item and I can add
another one and you can see that I'm now
getting multiple items right when we
look at this code obviously we may
wonder if this is good code given the
complexity of the problem that I'm
solving it's probably absolutely fine
okay but if this is actually a genuine
business problem we might begin to
wonder whether this is the right way to
do it
I've got quite a lot of repetition
around this idea of going and grabbing a
single item by ID and turning it into a
result object basically that I then put
out on on the wire right I do it there
and I do it there and I sort of
partition between the same bit of codes
just doing the same thing I've got quite
a lot of ideas mashed into my controller
right I've got here's my basically the
abstraction over here's my my context
basically for entity framework here's
some link statements you know talking to
the database here's this weird bit of
code that's basically writing out some
kind of console application so I
received some data logging in something
in some way maybe it's not the best idea
maybe maybe actually I can think of a
different way of structuring my
application so that all these different
ideas weren't mashed into the controller
and
as a thought experiment other thing to
think is let's say I've built this
originally in a different framework like
open raster or Nancy and then I decided
when net core came along you know what
I'm gonna use basically Web API I've
done that core be quite difficult to
transfer that code around right because
I have to take all this code out of the
controller and to figure out basically
what goes where or if I want to just use
a console application to call this how
would I do that so how would I swap over
the interface given that it's all there
any other questions how do I get this
under test right how do I test that gate
controller well I could potentially mate
I may be able to just spin up that
controller but actually it does some
weird things with that return okay and
tasks action results what am I going to
do with those and maybe I get some test
harness that lets me spin up controller
instances so that I can actually test my
code living in my controllers but now my
tests have taken a dependency on that
framework for testing MVC API
controllers and if I wanted to move that
code to a console window how do I know
that it works I've got to repeat the
tests now in the console window
I can't extract them away from that
testing harness so maybe there's some
kind of better way of doing all this
all right so that's just kind of setting
the scene for you and then we'll talk a
little bit about this idea who's who's
heard a loose coupling in high cohesion
as an idea okay most of you right so my
job title says that I'm a software
architect and a lot of people say well
what does a Software Architect - isn't
that just a highly paid developer that
isn't really true software architects
actually engage in a particular subjects
in a software engineering course or
architecture and one of the key
responsibilities that software
architects have is politician in a
petitioning really means breaking up the
system into pieces and the reason we
want to break the system up into pieces
was you want to improve basically the
modify ability of the system we want to
make it easy to change our software it
turns out that writing version one of
the software is usually very easy by
comparison to maintaining it I sort of
tweet recently by someone who'd gone to
work at Starbucks and he'd pre-fit
internally heading up their IT function
and he previously worked at digital
agency and digital agency is what you
tend to do is you support a given
advertising campaign I'm gonna produce
the site for the Han Solo movie and I'm
gonna do all the interaction for
customers and it's ephemeral doesn't
last very long it time to market is
really important he produced his
software and it dies and that was his
entire experience and when he got to
Starbucks he realized wow these guys
have got a huge problem that they've got
source code that's living for years
applications that live for years if
customers like to rewrite them and
really a lot of the developers here
they're one of their key focuses is how
do I maintain software how do I keep
that software alive and one of the
things so far architecture and theory
help us with is how do I make it easy to
maintain software and partitioning is a
key strategy towards doing that
and a clean architecture this concept
we're trying to talk about is one where
we say okay the partitioning will lead
to low coupling in a high cohesion what
do we mean by those statements
okay so coupling is this property of a
system though one
we make a change over here that ripples
and we end up basically with all these
things over here needing to change as
well okay so I change the interface that
I'm using by effectively changing the
signature of a given method call and
that has an effect that all the coolers
now need to be modified so those two
things are said to be coupled because
the change here represent effects those
things so we can have this direct
dependency style coupling where one
given module and you can read for that
anything class you know modules in
Python etc whatever your particular
preference is has a direct dependency
and it says if that changes I will
change but you can also have coupling
about knowledge okay so the algorithm
for calculating your insurance premium
lives in this module if I cut and paste
for that and put it in another module
I now have coupling between these two
modules voila that duplication so the
problem the duplication is really about
coupling duplication that has a problem
is a special case of coupling the reason
why some things even though they are
duplication are not something you need
to worry about like I call string.format
loads of times on my application should
I replace every call to string format
with another with another method cool
there are apps on my calls to string
format of course not because that's
Turtles all the way down right I don't
have to replace all the calls to that to
something else so you might say well
hang a minute isn't it you plication
there and the answer is it's not
duplication in terms of duplication of
knowledge so you haven't coupled to
things if both of these two modules
contain my algorithm for how I calculate
an insurance premium
if I change module a and I changed the
algorithm for how to code insurance
premium
if this module doesn't change then
essentially I have a problem that I'm
now calculating the insurance premium
correctly on both sides so I'm coupled
now you may think that's insane that
would never happen I used to work on a
complex risk management platform for mid
tier banks and we used to calculate a
whole range of statistics of traders
care about basically these Greeks as
they're called and we literally had on
different screens different numbers
because different algorithms have been
used to calculate those numbers on
different parts of the system and we had
a problem of coupling because we had
multiple representations of that piece
of knowledge so we can say something is
loosely coupled if a change to one item
doesn't result in a ripple effect and a
change to another item right and loose
coupling is something that is desirable
because it reduces the cost of change I
can just say hey this project involves
me changing our insurance algorithm I'm
gonna go and change these modules but
the rest of the system is fine there's
no impact all of the teams don't have to
worry okay and cohesion is the property
that were subject to the same forces of
change in a module a module at low
cohesion has many reasons to change
right if you just basically have one
module and everything is in there right
and it includes essentially my and
including sound building an insurance
application includes my management of
brokers it includes my claims sister
system for working with someone claims
against their household insurance policy
it includes my actuarial staff for
basically figuring out what life
insurance premium to charge you because
you smoke if all of that is in the same
module that I have lots of forces
wanting to change it right and the
problem with that is as soon as I change
your module really I have to retest that
module that's kind of my testing
boundary of a kind of
you a and it's also my boundary if I
start continuous integration and
rebuilding the software and why should
it be that my management of my
relationship with brokers is impacted
because you need to change the algorithm
deciding and how much your insurance
premiums should be because you smoke
okay so if I have unrelated ideas in the
same module and have different forces of
change we tend to say essentially that a
module has a low cohesion okay and I'm
Roger that has low cohesion has Timmy
reasons to change and that results in
basically the code smell we called
divergent change okay all right let's
talk a bit about layering this is a
classic layering model sit diagram of
system who is built a system with layers
okay and everyone in the room right this
is a classic three layer model at the
top essentially I have my presentation
logic my UI so this essentially is where
effectively I have my MVC and I a layer
of a pattern where effectively I figure
out what I'm going to put out my web api
what I'm going to put out basic HTML I'm
gonna play out via MVC or maybe I'm in
actually in a rich client and I want to
talk about basically what happens on my
windows for WPF page right down below
that I have my domain model right that
is the business logic that's how I
figure out what I'm doing that's where I
calculate your insurance premium that's
where essentially I deal with your claim
for your water tank having burst and
down the bottom I've got the
infrastructure layer quite often
referred to as the data layer but it's
essentially where I'm doing things like
getting data talking to a third party
system to look up zip codes or post
codes etc right and the key idea in this
layered architecture is that dependency
is always downwards okay so I depend
down and that means I don't end up with
these notions of circle dependencies
which are bad right if module a depends
on module C and module C depends on
module a I have trouble building any one
of them because to build you
always building the other side and then
building the other side involves
building you and what happens if you
both have changes all right that's going
to be a problem so we want to basically
remove those cycles from our modules but
the value of layers it's not just in
that dependency it's in the abstraction
they provide essentially layers help us
partition the system we could take what
are you while I can punch them put them
in a liar and that is what we reason
about UI ok and I could SWAT that a
layer for something else right my NBC my
web api layer could be replaced with a
console layer so I can actually come my
lan interface everything you know
because I've realized that the come
Milan interface is best that's really
what we should be forcing our customers
to do again not in this JavaScript HTML
nonsense they were better off when they
just typed it'll two little codes into
the console right or effectively I can
actually have it so it's basically
wynant's talking for web api ones
talking to my MVC layer that's from
presentation layers that I want okay so
I can swap out basically my
infrastructure layer right I can decide
a sexy to have an in-memory database for
testing I can decide n to use a real
database obviously essentially for
actual production code or maybe I don't
maybe a siding maybe a face is good
enough and the in name structural layer
I may have for example third party
services that I'm calling let's say I'm
calling payment systems or maybe calling
lookups for ZIP codes and it's quite
possible there commercial providers who
I have a falling-out with because
they're their service quality is rubbish
and I don't want to replace them with
somebody else by putting it in a layer
down below and partitioning off I only
have to replace that portion of the
software the domain is not impacted by
me wanting to swap out the payment
provider
okay so layering is a very useful
partitioning of the system because it
helps us to understand the system more
ease we can reason about what's
happening in one layer without having to
about with something the other layers
and we can swap out pieces that we
basically have decided up we want to
change so it's a sports change and so we
get some cuts of cohesion and reduced
coupling by using layering
stupid okay one thing to note on this
basically is the quite common approach
here that says actually I'm gonna split
my domain into two kind of legal sub
layers and a partition my domain lot
layer further I'm gonna start thinking
about that as having a service layer and
an entity layer and the service layer is
going to contain my application logic
and we'll talk more about what that is
during the this conversation together
and my entity layer is essentially going
to retain basically my state and
behavior around that state okay so we
can distinguish two types of business
logic domain logic has something to do
purely with the domain right it's
basically saying this is basically how I
calculate your insurance premium
depending upon the variable so you have
given me whether you smoke whether
you're single whether you have kids
whether you drive a fast car whether
you're a journalist apparently that's a
big no-no and that information tends to
be basically what we can we consider
logic belonging to the actual objects in
the domain an application logic which is
really to do with coordinating those
pieces in order to fill some requests I
may actually need to talk to two or
three objects I might want to create a
transaction to make sure that I have
transactional integrity in the system I
might want to raise events to downstream
systems to let them know that something
happened and this is not a
responsibility of the domain but it is a
responsibility we need to fulfill if we
are to basically provide these services
that someone is expecting from our
application so the service layer
provides application logic right so we
talk about it between services to the
service line the entity layer the
service that's provided in their
application logic right the coordination
in control logic fraud
the workflow for it one of this key
responsibilities quite often is simply
to load the domain model alright but the
main model essentially it doesn't exist
until you load it from the database you
can think their main the domain the
entities set your system is kind of like
a rules engine right way rules engines
work is you declare a whole series of
facts and rules and then essentially
what you have to do is to populate those
facts and rules with data and then
exercise the rules and say what happens
and really you're doing the same thing
your application logic layer is saying
I'm going to load these objects into the
domain model populate them in with these
facts and then exercise of the main
model load this customer look at their
details now calculate their insurance
premium you don't always want to do that
right this is a bit of a caveat here
sometimes actually your domain is very
anemic and you should justly accept that
don't people talk about anemic domain
model as that some bad anti-pattern that
essentially you must never have you
shouldn't have it anemic domain model if
you do have a rich domain but sometimes
actually your domain consists of storing
stuff right and that's fine
in writing a customer contact database
probably there's not a lot of actual
detail and you may be okay with a data
structure and application logic to
control it don't panic if that happens
to you that's absolutely fine okay
that's where we can put things like
transaction control security there's all
thorgan all aspects of our application
and we service a request there are many
things we think of as orthogonal you
know transaction control or availability
retry logic all those kind of things and
we can put those in our application
logic okay two basic implementation
variate variations the service layer
says basically I have a very thin facade
to have a class or a procedure that
essentially says I just really directly
call entity level objects to do all the
work I'm not doing very much at all and
there's really no business logic crept
into my basically upper layer okay and
the operation script approach says
actually I have some more
responsibilities here okay I'm actually
going to basically have some kind of
business logic because this business
operation is fulfilled by a number of
entities which we care about cooperating
so actually it's okay there is actually
some business logic here and there are
two variations on basically the same
idea okay classically what we get most
of you have probably seen this pattern
in the few still to any historic netcode
you'll get a class it ends in service is
equal to my orders service it has a lot
of methods on it and those methods that
present operations on orders we cloak
them all together and put them in one
big class quite often it's static we
just said we don't create the instances
of it and that pattern has been around
in things like dotnet and Java for quite
some time okay I'm tend to call it the
minute order service all right so maybe
such a port was in then when I when I
switch do you probably going okay to
pause to me it's like I said the cat
Erna T okay that's what I can do is I
can say well maybe we could rewrite this
controller so we're going to use this
notion of a service flower I'm just
calling a facade here a facade is a name
ready for a class that acts essentially
as a coarse-grained interface to the
more granular classes below it and so
that's a typical service layer pattern
so now I'm just saying how I'll call my
facade and get all of my tasks call my
facade and get that one task right and
you can see once again the things about
post that's starting to pay off because
that common notion I had of getting one
task is now one bit of code that
essentially I can repeat okay and
operations like a degree these things
look much simpler now in my controller I
get a little bit click I look some more
clarity about what I'm doing in response
to an HTTP request
I build this one and show you it still
works but I won't do it for every single
variation because we're running out of
time but I'll do that when I'm talking
about it when I go and look at this
facade what does he look like
well so what it turns out is I've mostly
done he's just taken that code that was
in the controller I moved it down one
layer and provide some kind of
abstraction okay and that may seem well
that's not very much in but I have
removed some duplication repetition
right I've now got one guy AC method so
that may be a help to me and so every
time I basically want to fix problem mr.
do with basically getting a single
request to getting multiple requests
then actually buddy got one placing to
fix it or if I wanted to modify my
strategy because it was unperformed I
got one place to go and fix that but in
addition because I've actually taken it
out of the controller
I've actually improved a number of other
things I could do I could test now at
this layer right throughout my tests
directly against my facade which means
even though I'm testing the important
logic I've removed the need to
instantiate that popped that troublesome
controller so my tests are no longer
dependent on that framework my tests are
now depending on my code and that's
always good because it means that
essentially my tests are continue to
exercise the work that I'm doing that
everybody else is
this just a little bit of a strange one
and we'll come back to that later but
we've managed to push this code which to
place you push them into the console out
as well
and that's actually giving us a bit of
cleanness and clarity okay so that's
kind of a typical first step that people
will use when they're building stuff let
me just run that through and I can show
you it still works I say that I mean it
probably just fell on me and would feel
like all this time we spent watching a
build hasn't really helped us so we're
just using docker because it's simple to
run up some infrastructure if we come
over here again and we find our test
HTTP file so case then we get asked the
question and what is this so this is
basically a plugin for code called
restclient
which lets you essentially exercise curl
statements and get feedback from them so
you can see basically I already had a
couple of entries in database Allison
Mary from last time I can add new
entries into the database and I can
retrieve them so functionally I'm the
same and actually these tests which work
against the API continue to function
normally even though I've moved things
down a liar right
so turns out there's an interesting idea
in layered architecture called ports and
adapters and we referred to that earlier
right this is one of the ideas that Bob
Malin began to look at when he decided
to get to waters idea of clean
architecture what a ports adapters
architectural style basically this is a
variation of the layered architecture
which has three key layers it has the
application layer which essentially the
business logic lives right and you can
think of that essentially in the
previous as being roughly equivalent to
our domain that's where essentially our
business logic is gonna live and it's
got the adapter layer which represents
all the things that essentially are
talking something outside the system so
all of the i/o is a beauty we're
thinking about it right so the adapter
layer is basically a layer that says
well here is how we talk to the user of
our interface right here is where my MVC
code lives here is where my windows form
with code lives here is where my WPF
code lives here is where my console
lives okay but in addition to that it
also includes which we tend to think of
basically as primary adapters right
because I talk to a primary actor which
is basically a user usually interacting
with the system it also actually adaptil
there includes my database my third
party service that I call to look up
postal zip codes or to look up
essentially the weather today right so
it has what we call secondary adapters
or secondary actors which talk to
secondary actors which are things
outside the system that I need to use
depend on for the service off and then
this model interestingly enough where
especially when we look to previous
models let me get back we had this
notion of a separation between the
domain of the infrastructure here we
don't have that anymore
we have this one adapter layer
and we've got this funny notion which
confuses everyone a port and a port is
what lives between the adapter and the
domain layer right and it's referred to
by Arthur Coburn as a purposeful
conversation so it's a conversation that
occurred between their adapter and the
domain so it's more than just simply the
interfaces to the limit of the entity
types living the application there's
something else going on
just notion of personal application and
he refers to effectively as the API of
our application and by that word
application he means what's at the core
what's at the center ok and the goal
here is to utterly decouple or
application from any technology concerns
so if you look at this diagram which is
a classic diagram of a hexagonal
architecture what you will see is in the
center for to represent with those
circles a whole load of entities they're
basically our domain classes to
represent how we provide the
functionality of our application in the
outs outer layers they see feeds user
side notifications database these
essentially is the adapter layer that's
how we talk to the outside world so on
the user side for example we have an
adapter for HTTP for basically providing
an API via HTTP we have a GUI adapter so
we can provide and the an MVC layer so
we can actually see stuff right over
here on the photo database side
basically we have a database adapter I
can they're taught for database I can
get information in or out right I've got
notifications layer so maybe I want to
raise our two vacations via message
queue some gunnies am keep eve base to
raise messages or I've got WebSockets
or I'm sending emails right so this
adapter layers how I talk to those
external concerns a deficit separate
process my message queues a separate
process my emails an SMTP server my
WebSockets were sexy our HTTP over the
wire I've got HTTP I've got going to be
CI users browse on the
right so the adapters manage the
interaction with the outside world and
the port is essentially what lives in
between the adapter and the application
so that's the adapter that's the
application and that's support so when
Colvin says effectively the port is the
purpose or conversation effectively
between the outside world and the
application he's referring to that
application layer there okay one of the
interesting properties of this model is
that all dependencies are in words okay
so the adapter layer is allowed to
depend on the port and the poor is got
to depend on the app on the application
but the application is not allowed to
depend upwards so my application can not
cool my database directly so if we look
at our layering model we can see that
essentially the adapter layer has both
our infrastructure and our UI and our
domain our application layer has
basically has our port our application
inside in our domain layer so the
question might be what hang on a minute
if I need to talk to database to get my
data effectively in my hydrate my model
how do I do that
okay from my domain model and the answer
is you have to use dependency inversion
so within my port if I want to basically
talk to it and adapt to some piece of
infrastructure or UI so if I'm talking
to the database I define an interface
and that's basically something like my
repository pattern my repository on my
Dao pad my ID I oh right or my gateway
for a messaging system it's my high
messaging gateway and that says at the
port level what I want to do is
understand and I'm talking to the
outside world but I can't depend on
anything concrete above me so what I
must do essentially is say you have to
basically depend on the interface and
then as a concrete implementation of the
interface provided when I spend the
application up
what happens in my mane at the beginning
of my application which is what's called
the composition route the place
essentially where I hook everything
together then essentially I register an
implementation of that interface with a
container which I can later then
essentially use an ioc container or
poor-man's a poor-man's di to
essentially inject into the application
okay and by doing that I preserve the
clean that the cleanliness of my
application okay it's not about domains
a little bit well just took another run
at the same idea some clarity right so
back in about 1992 I think I live a
jakob sin wrote a book called
object-oriented software engineering
didn't read it
Wow almost nobody I see a few hands but
yeah so this used to be like one of the
texts photo oh right if you were a pro
gamer back in the 90s this was kind of
the texts that you read and what this
text is most famous for probably is
introducing the idea of use cases who's
heard of use cases yay okay
nowadays gee honest with you you can
think of the user story as it's a very
lightweight use case and that's
essentially would be co-pastor Coburn's
definition of a user story this is a
lightweight informal use case it does
what a use case does but essentially it
says it doesn't have a reformer syntax
this is a more form wallet presentation
I pulled off the internet somewhere of
someone doing a use case those circles
essentially represent use cases and
someone's going to look at what a
business processes in a restaurant and
said what are the key use cases that we
have to do so let's say I wanted to
basically you know automate and give the
server a handheld so they could
essentially do all the interaction with
the customer and a handheld these were
the kind of use cases I'd start to look
at and the use case essentially says
what are the steps that I have to
complete inside your application in
order to provide some kind of useful
functionality to the user you can think
of it as kind of a scenario if you like
right in order to essentially
order food the following things will
have to happen you know I have to
basically send a ticket back to the
system that basically has a list of food
orders etc and the second thing though
that is in that book that yeah Kirsten
came up with a thing called boundary
controller entity or BCE who said it BCE
a couple people right that's actually
quite unusual so BC EU is quite a
popular model at that period of time and
essentially it's a model of how you
slice up the software okay so a boundary
that symbol is it's your mouth symbol so
this is part of the UML standard the
boundary is that object basically that
interfaces with system actors user
interfaces gateways and proxies right so
essentially the boundary is an object on
the outside of your system and it says
the actor which essentially is a human
being pressing buttons on your system or
something it was system talks to write
the interface with that is handled by a
boundary object sound a bit familiar
here's a diagram from epson's book
showing essentially actors right so I've
basically got looking at my customer
panel someone's got a receipt I've got
basically an operator who's looking at
an operator pan or alarm devices okay so
this boundary object is how I interact
with the system and there are entities
in your system and the entities of the
objects that store system data and they
also contain the business rules about
that data if we think about IO which is
really where this model comes from we
really want to have or their databases
have kind of killed their model for us
implementation hiding okay
and so implementation hiding is the idea
that we're basically hiding our state so
the rules affecting that state you have
to live in the entity and then finally
controller objects some people have
renamed interactors to avoid confusion
with things like controllers in the MVC
Pan
which mediate which with the boundary
between the between boundaries and
entities so they orchestrate the
execution of commands coming from
basically the boundary and if the use
case is a description of the way the
system is being used then a control or
interactor is the implementation of that
use case so our use cases live in this
control or interact tool and this is a
typical diagram I have an actor he
basically interact to the boundary some
sort of UI
the UI in turn calls some kind of
control objects essentially to do some
work which has said to the other use
cases and should be named after the use
case for something I order food or ever
etc which in turn orchestrate the
entities there are some rules actors can
act the talk to boundaries balance can
talk to controllers controllers can talk
to controllers controls talk to entities
but actors should never talk to
controllers directly or to entities
directly and boundaries should not talk
basically to entities or to other
boundaries that only may have to relax I
suspect and entities should not tortured
entities the idea originally was that
essentially a boundary and an entity are
noun and nouns can't talk to nouns now
it's going to talk to verbs and the
controller is a verb all right but we
can see this model has some parallels to
the models we've been building up so far
right we have this idea essentially or a
boundary object to control object
essentially and they are really are very
much close to the adapter in the port
and the application model okay and
indeed Coburn says a port is the
use-case boundary right this is where we
define our steps so we can relook at
this hexagonal architecture and say ah
well that's basically our boundary
objects they're our entity objects and
in between our control objects so it's
problematic thing the port people get
concerned about when building these
architectures is really just essentially
their control objects all right there's
a correlation between the use case Brown
during the test boundary so what are the
advantages of a hexagonal architecture
is we can begin to write our tests
cleanly against this control boundary
because those are the used cases in the
system we want to test
and so you write your unit tests against
that control layer not against the
boundary layer and if you need to then
essentially you can write some
integration test to confirm you've
hooked up your boundary layer correctly
otherwise you rely on system tests to
prove everything works end to end
because I just proved when I switched
between my different layers then
essentially that still works my it's my
test still worked even though I began to
move stuff down the layering okay so
this is Bob's model of the clean
architecture and essentially used to
ride from all those other earlier
architectures right so you can think of
the blue layer is basically your
boundary or adapter layer the controller
green layer is your ports layer where
other blue layer effects we saw the
outside world the green areas are
adapters the blue could be frameworks
like MVC for you the green layer is your
adapters your controllers the things
that plug in to the outer layer usually
all your repositories your gateways your
messaging system the pinky-orange layer
the salmon layer is essentially the use
cases that's your ports layer that's
where effectively these cases the system
are exposed and there you have your
entities right this is how kind of well
it looks you essentially have a boundary
layer which talks to some interactors
which talks to the entities okay and you
may have a request in a response model
which essentially are when the boundary
comes in it delivers a request so your
HTTP request comes in we take all the
things in the header we take all the
body when we give it over to the
interactor and say deal with this for me
it goes and calls the entities and deals
with the requests and it generates
basically a response model what's the
result of that happening the response
model then gets pushed out by the
adapter and goes back to the user
okay if you have an MVC layer then
essentially as part of that controller
right so your controller is an
implementation of the presenter and
essentially your response model is a
view model that you are the pin putting
out onto the view graph and the view is
hidden from user at Web API right the
view is I just returned my object and it
puts as Jason for me my entity gateway
is essentially how my interactor talks
to the adapter layer so interface we
thought we looked at earlier for
basically dependency
Injection that says i'm going to be
basically how you talk to the database
and the implementation of it is
something like a repository pattern or
RDA oh okay
so let's be to this bit quite fast what
I might do actually just say some code
here at the time
right so given I start with this facade
then what can I do well the first thing
I might want to do with my facade is
essentially say well when I look at my
facade there's a slight problem with it
and the problem is that the facade has
too many concerns together okay and so
because it has all those same concerns
in my one facade it's too many forces of
change so I could break my facade up and
have a whole set of facades instead an
hour greeting service that just handles
the proportion of the words is that a de
greeting a greeting is all service that
gets me all the greetings back a
greeting is by our ID service that gets
me all those individual greetings right
so take that big service model and I
break it up I say actually that's too
much I don't want to do that because all
the forces I don't have suffered two
interfaces for different customers and
some clients and it's hard to reuse I
have to reuse the whole facade even if I
only want one operation but it turns out
that model is really just commands so
the command pattern essentially says I
want to encapsulate the idea of calling
the domain part of in some kind of
transactional boundary and there's a
strong alignment then between this idea
of a command model and a use case so I
can turn those individual Fusaro items
into commands so I'm just implementing
an interface on command which is
basically a standard interface
essentially we're idea whoops I'm not
gonna navigate to that there anyone it's
somewhere around I will find a bit later
so we're saying I can execute right and
here I'm basically just doing the add or
I'm gonna delete something okay when I
get to my controller now I've got this
nice idea of a command I'm going to add
a greeting right that's some kind of use
case that I'm implementing here right it
add my greeting and my queries are
similarly really just a variation of the
same idea I'm gonna encapsulate the idea
of queer
doing this query for you where's my
query and so there I'm just going to
execute that same code I had at the
beginning as a query object and these
are my interactors these are my ports
right representation of my use cases in
the system so what I'm doing here for
example as I'm saying when I get in the
request model create an interactive the
a greeting command pass in the data from
that request model execute it in other
words exercise the underlying entities
my greeting model and then essentially
I'm gonna raise in the vent out as well
we'll come back to that bit later and
then essentially call a query object to
build my response model right so my so
I'm basically using interactors which
are present use cases to handle the
request and response model by exercising
the entities and the volunteers are
basically using some kind of command
model is what I can actually do is use a
framework and this is using brighter but
mediator etc have similar ideas and I
can say I'm going to separate creating
the command from executing it why might
I do that or if we go and look at add
command
handler rather the kamati the receiver
for that a greeting command okay we can
see I have some attributes on there and
those attributes are handling orthogonal
items such as retry logic try and talk
to database it fail just retry maybe
it's a temporary error maybe it's a
deadlock you are trying to basically it
felt a lot that way seems to be down
break the circuit don't make calls on
here anymore give the user a too many
requests and get them to slow down okay
I want to log this so that port layer
that interactive layer is also a very
useful layer for us to intercept and
provide not just basically workflow
logic but control logic for our
application and we can insert that into
the pipeline without really having to
have any awareness of it when we look at
the application logic is cleanly
separated so I can read my application
logic I can understand what's going on
but I'm able to add that on top and my
controller looks fairly clean right I'm
quoting my interactor the algorithm
command said she well I've got two
parameters my interactor I'm exercising
my interacting indirectly through this
dispatcher so that I can essentially
have a pipeline of operations that it
calls until I get to the entity model
right so both letters for immediately
does this for you they're all basically
variations the same thing okay so let's
go through these reasonably fast so what
I was doing there since she was saying
well I had some service facade
I was woried essentially that that I had
a problem with effectively too many
concerns grouped together so I broke it
up into series of separate interfaces of
my service certain intuitive parts I
then essentially said well effectively
they can all be individual services
individually interact as rather than one
big interactive that's everything I said
well okay those individual interactors
that are broken up with just a command
pan and the command pan is very useful
to me because the command pan
semantically is a transaction it
a use case and therefore it Maps really
nicely to this idea within the clean
architecture of an interactive this
controller from the BCE model of the
port from a hexagonal architecture model
okay and it simply separates the caller
from the entity model that's its job is
to separate basically the caller from
the entity model it's exactly what a
controller does it separates the
boundary from the entity model okay
standard Facebook commands and so I can
see essentially my interactive model is
effectively my command interface query
objects which are essentially just
affecting this idea of assembler that
goes away look operates over my domain
and produces basically some kind of data
transfer object a view model so I can
create those as well the idea basically
of saying but to build my response model
what I want to do is have some kind of
object it's an interactive
that reads my domain generates basically
an output response and of course I don't
get to detail in this slide but that
leads to the idea of CQRS this
separation between the query side
objects and the command side objects
okay
this talk is not about CTRs so that's
the details slide I understand that but
the goal is reached to hint to you
little to go down that route and then we
also took a command dispatcher which is
this an idea or effectively that I can
separate the parameters of the command
from the execution body so that I can
insert operations between essentially
the point I call in the boundary and the
point effectively they're each the
entity so essentially I can chain
controllers together to separate the
responsibilities of those controllers so
that some of my controllers do logging
some of my controllers do retry logic
some of my controllers do transactional
control some of them do authorization
control and when the ones at the end
just do workflow so I can separate all
those responsibilities so that the only
change because I'm changing that type of
thing I'm gonna change ID logging I want
to replace the login framework I'm using
I'm gonna change how I do retry logic
I'm gonna I'm gonna only knock the use
poly I'm gonna implant something myself
that's the time I just showed you all
right so I think we are about on time so
I got time for any questions a lot to
take in the book to go and read is Bob
Martin's book she showed you the
beginning clean architecture and also
his blog post you should you can go
under the hexagonal architecture online
there's a good discussion basically
you're Alistair Coburn site hexagonal
architectures and BCE is hard to define
information about nowadays because it's
a kind of that use case that everything
else is older but there are various
sources on the web talking about how BCE
works and there's some blog posts
relating to Bob minds clean architecture
where people actually talk a little bit
about how BC model used to work people
fix it up from but it's a very the BC
model is really mainly useful because
people like Coburn at the time he was
writing here taking our attention you
all about BCE and the it's kind of
implied you understand use cases in BCE
you wouldn't talk about that now
supports become very confusing all right
if you have questions because we're out
of time I said you come down the front
and I'll take them in the break police
remember to tradition of putting green
tickets in the box it's a local
tradition which you should all honor as
you leave and thanks very much
[Applause]